what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back again with another installment
of our beyond omega level series where
we break down the origins and powers of
the most powerful characters in comics
and for today's video we're technically
revisiting a character that we've
already covered in this series the
batman who laughs but in this video
we're actually focusing on his darkest
night version which is a far more
powerful version of the batman who
laughs and i think he's different enough
and powerful enough to merit giving him
his own video so the batman who laughs
as most of you guys know was created by
scott snyder and greg capullo and first
appeared in dark days the casting number
one in 2017 with his first full
appearance coming in teen titans number
12. and this guy is basically just bruce
wayne from earth negative 22 who has
pretty much the same origin story as the
batman of the main dc continuity right
his parents get murdered when he was
young he endures years of training to
become a vigilante dedicated to rid
gotham city of crime and eventually
becomes batman now like the main version
of batman the joker is his arch nemesis
but this version of the joker figures
out the joker toxin that he'd been using
was actually killing him so he kills all
of batman's other rogues as well as
commissioner gordon because he just
wanted to take out as many people as he
could before he died but the joker then
drugs batman which paralyzes him and
continues his killing spree with batman
forced to watch but unable to stop him
now when the drug wears off and batman
moves again he kills the joker but when
he dies the joker releases some of the
toxin within his heart which infects
batman now a few days later batman
summons his allies right nightwing
batgirl red robin and red hood to the
bat cave and murders them because he
knew they would be the first to notice
that the joker toxin was changing him
and he needed them out of the way
basically now the batman who laughs is
then able to kill the rest of the
justice league using weapons stored at
the watchtower and uses black kryptonite
to drive superman and his son john
insane driving them to kill lois lane
and each other now from this point on
bruce wayne becomes the batman who
laughs a hybrid of batman and joker and
convinces his son damian to take the
joker toxin to become one of his robins
alongside some of the other children
that have been transformed by the toxin
by the joker prior to his death and so
that's basically the origin of the
batman who laughs which you have to
understand in order to understand the
darkest knife but the batman who laughs
eventually conquers his entire universe
of earth negative 22 and later learns
that as part of an entire dark
multiverse when he's enlisted to help
barbados a bad god bent on destroying
the multiverse during the events of dark
knight's metal this storyline of course
saw the batman who last recruiting
different versions of batman from the
dark multiverse to invade the dc
positive multiverse and it was a whole
big thing that i have a full story video
on if you guys want to check it out but
after he was introduced the batman who
laughs became extremely popular and was
literally everywhere in dc comics for
like three years so much so that fans
actually grew to hate him now for the
purposes of this video we don't have to
get into everything the batman who
laughs dead after dark knight's medal
but instead we're going to focus on what
led to him assuming his final form the
darkest night so once barbados is
defeated a new villain showed up in the
form of perpetua who was responsible for
creating the dc multiverse but who had
been imprisoned within the source wall
for billions of years for disrupting the
multiversal balance by not giving up her
life upon creating the multiverse and
then creating a group of apex predators
by emerging martians and humans now
after perpetua is freed she goes around
basically destroying universes and of
course eventually sets her sights on the
dc universe now while she had originally
chosen lex luthor as her lieutenant and
really the guy who led the show in her
stead and transformed him into an apex
predator he was eventually replaced by
the batman who laughs who had heard
about perpetua from barbados and
convinced her that he not luther should
be her leading man shortly thereafter
however the batman who laughs battles
the justice league and is killed by
wonder woman who uses a weapon known as
the chainsaw of truth which was
basically crafted from parts of her
invisible jet to essentially take out
batman but because he is batman even if
he is an alternate reality version of
batman he of course has a contingency
plan in place in the event of his death
in this case he had observed a version
of bruce wayne that had found the button
belonging to the comedian of the
watchmen and had built a machine to
study it and so the batman who laughs
traps this version of bruce wayne in the
machine and then turns it on replicating
the incident that he created dr
manhattan in the watchman universe and
effectively turning that version of
bruce wayne into dr manhattan and so the
batman who laughs quickly lobotomizes
this version of bruce and then puts his
comatose body away for safe keeping now
after he's killed by wonder woman the
batman who laughs followers take his
brain and implant it in the body of the
doctor manhattan bruce wayne becoming a
new entity that he calls bat hat yeah
it's a really stupid name and if you
know anything about dr manhattan you'll
know that his powers are incredibly vast
and they basically amount to near
omnipotence as dr manhattan is able to
manipulate matter on a molecular scale
and warp reality so he's already an
extremely powerful entity upon becoming
this guy we're not going to call him
batman hat that's a stupid name but he
would not remain in this form for long
as he would soon remake himself into a
thin wraith-like being of pure energy
and then dub himself the darkest knife
now the darkest knight's goal was to
prevent wonder woman from recruiting the
multiverse and instead create one in his
own image that contains 52 planets of
nightmares which he basically called the
last 52. to do this he seeks out wally
west who would also gain the powers of
dr manhattan after sitting on the mobius
chair which of course is a chair that
grants those who sit in it near
omniscience although wally and his
fellow flashes jay garrick and barry
allen try to flee they're unable to
defeat the darkest knight's plans as it
turns out the darkest knight had altered
the mobius chair so that it sent all the
energy intended for wall-e directly to
him making him vastly more powerful than
he already was and turning him into
probably the most powerful entity in the
multiverse now before he goes through
this plan to create the last 52
multiverse he confronts perpetua who
keep in mind created the multiverse and
is able to kill her by trapping her
within pieces of the source wall so not
only can the darkest knight create
multiverses in his own image he was also
able to kill what up to that point was
probably the most powerful character
introduced in dc comics with the
exception of the presence which is
basically dc's version of god but even
then it's slightly debatable now at this
point you may wonder how a character as
powerful as the darkest knight was ever
even defeated and the answer is plot
armor quite literally wonder woman shows
up clad in golden armor and battles the
darkest knight through space and time
and the two go all the way back to the
moment perpetua created the universe and
all the way forward to the moment just
before the universe's sun burns out
because the universe has a singular sun
but despite pleading with wonder woman
to join him and prevent the destruction
of the universe by the hands the race of
beings that perpetua had once belonged
to wonder woman refuses and the darkest
knight dies after being thrown into the
coalescence of energy that is the end of
all things and so that's basically
everything you need to know about
darkest night now as for his powers they
were pretty much anything he wanted them
to be after getting the powers of dr
manhattan and having them augmented by
stealing wally west powers as well as
the energy he absorbed through the
mobius chair the darkest knight
essentially became god with the power to
create an entire multiverse so he was
pretty much omnipotent meaning there was
effectively no limit to what his powers
were he was also nearly omniscient and
was aware of almost everything going on
throughout the multiverse and had the
ability to perceive the past present and
future simultaneously which begs the
question how is he defeated by wonder
woman but being nearly omniscient and
omnipotent the darkest knight probably
needs to be categorized as whatever is
beyond beyond omega level i have no idea
what that would be i don't know beyond
omega level squared let me know what you
guys think down in the comments section
but thank you guys for watching this
video and i will catch you all later
peace